making their way into a dilapidated
underground bunker these pictures are
from the azov battalion of ukraine's
armed forces
they appear to show soldiers bringing
food for women and children
this is somewhere in the azov style
steel plant the last remaining part of
mario paul not under russian control
the soldiers say they brought gifts for
the kids but what they really want is to
see the outside world
we've been playing games on the phone
says this girl but we want to go home we
want to see the sun
this girl's father worked here now she
and her mother are sheltering in the
bunker after leaving her grandparents
behind they've been here for almost
eight weeks a soldier mentions the
possibility of being evacuated to safety
we hope so we're running out of food
comes the reply
on friday russian forces took
journalists to part of the industrial
complex that's been badly damaged video
apparently shows a shell exploding
other pictures also showed black smoke
rising from the site
most of mariopol has been destroyed by
weeks of russian bombardment and intense
street fighting
as the kremlin said the city had
returned to normal some civilians
ventured out from shelters
i've stayed in the basement everything's
been blown up three more shells blasted
nearby yesterday one person was crushed
to death after the rescue efforts failed
and an elderly woman died too
the human cost of the onslaught is still
emerging satellite images just released
but taken at the end of last month are
said to show large freshly dug trenches
in a cemetery east of mariupol the local
mayor has accused russian forces of
burying bodies in mass graves
these chechen fighters claim to have
cleansed and destroyed mario paul along
with russian forces the video was posted
on social media by ramzan kadyrov head
of the republic of chechnya and a key
ally to president putin
but ukraine says tens of thousands of
civilians have been killed here with a
hundred thousand still trapped
and these children don't know when they
can go home or if they even have one
nadeem baba al jazeera